- Hello, Sal here from Khan Academy.
So when you hear the word meditation,
for many of y'all, it
might evoke some type of
new age thing that has nothing to do
with standardize tests.
And if you're about to
take a standardize test,
I'm sure there's many thoughts about
am I prepared, am I going to do well,
I hope I don't bomb the exam.
That stress and that anxiety
is, if anything, going
to hurt your performance
on these things that you wanna do well.
And so, meditation is a
way to help still that.
But it's really just for you
to observe your thoughts,
not get stressed out about
it if your thoughts start
to wander, but then just bring them back
and try to not think.
Or think about just
very positive thoughts.
I think if you do that you're
gonna find you're gonna be
happier, you're gonna be more positive,
all sorts of positive energy
is going to be attracted
to you, and, even though
that's not the most important
thing in the world, you'll
do just fine on these tests
that right now you
might be worrying about.